[music]
the red cross sloanes have just arrived at the place of the garden,
as the kids call
everyone sent a wonderful all the current their
faces slide yesterday before
[music] the
shelling was so strong and next
to us all the time the exit from the bunker was falling
where the first steps it could be
though  if pasha’s bunker didn’t have enough
oxygen about
1 and go out at least breathe after all, after all,
two oxygen entering housing it,
as they say, I was afraid of garbage in the light of
you gray darkness, I’m going with my husband on the
bus, I say Basya, we didn’t see the
sun, we were afraid of
this very thing  I flew the terrible myself,
I play on giving, and this is the most
terrible thing when they are on you in a
way
[music]
recently print everything according to the dress of the people
behind the joint if the beard is the lower right
grief of the letters, the radius of the sample and the stations are
sighted any
[music]